l'intérêt c'est que ça permettrait de
faire un autoroute qui lie les quartiers
pour aller au travail le matin et le
soir pour les gens surtout en vélo
puisque la voix est très large il ya
l'équivalent de quatre voies de train et
donc ça peut être utilisé donc dans un
but pratique pour la vie de tous les
jours pour les gens qui travaillent
aussi bas comme un endroit pour pour se
détendre le week-end ou le soir après le
travail
comme vous pouvez le voir sur la partie
élevée ya beaucoup de l'ancienne usine
c'est à ces industriels
donc il ya beaucoup de bâtiments qui
sont abandonnés beaucoup d'endroits
l'espace de terrain qui sont vides
donc comme pour l'allan à new york il ya
un énorme potentiel au niveau immobilier
bon à l'heure actuelle donc il ya eu
seulement la première phase qui est
prévue qui est une phase assez assez
courtes petit en taille c'est ça
représente 1/3 de marc je pense que
c'est une bonne idée commencer petit et
ça permettra de d'avoir le support total
je pense tous les habitants de
philadelphie est et de toutes les
institutions et les personnes qui feront
que la suite pourra continuer